རྫོགས་རས་འདི། རྫོགས་ཡོད་མ་༼རས་༽ བཤད་༼གི་༽མིན།
ཆུ་དགོས།
༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽སེ་འཐུང་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན། འགྲིག་སོང་།
སྤྲད་(ད)།
འདི་ལ་འཚལ་དགོས།
ག་བ་ལ།
ཚར་ཚར་སོང་།
མ་བྱེད།
འདི་ཡག་པོ་འདུག
ང་ལ།
སྤྲད་(ད)།
ང་༼ཁ་གྱི་༽བསིལ་ལྷམ་ག་བ། ཨ།
བརྡབ་༼གི་༽མ་རེད།
ང་ཚོ་༼ཁ་གྱི་༽ག་བ།
ང་༼ཁ་གྱི་༽རྩེད་མོ། ཨ།
ཨ་ཅག་བྱི་རིལ་ཟ་ཚར་ཡིན་པས།
ད་(ར)། ག་རེ་བྱས་སོང་ལབ་དགོས་བས། འདི་ཡོང་གི་མི་འདུག
རྡུང་གི་མི་འདུག་(ར)། རྔན་པ་སྤྲད་སོང་།
ད་ལྟ།
སྣང་སྲས་ཡག་པོ༼ཁོ་ར་༽མི་འདུག
ལགས་༼གིས༽།
ད་ལྟ།
ལགས་༼གིས་༽མིག་ཤེལ་སྤྲད་སོང་།
ཁ་ལག ༼ཨི་འདྲས༽། ནག་པོ།
སྤྲད་(ད)།
སྙིང་རྗེ་བོ་འདུག་འདི། འདི།
མཐོང་གི་འདུག མཐོང་གི་འདུག་ང་། ད་ལྟ་ར་ནང་སྒོ་བརྒྱབ་༼ཞག༽
འདི་ལ་ལྟ་(ད)།
སྒོ་བརྒྱབ་མི་འདུག་(ག) རྫོན་མ་བཤད་ཡིན།
ད་ལྟ་ར་ཨ་མ་དང་པ་ལགས་རྩར་ལ་འགྲོ་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
པ་ལགས་ལ་འགྲོ་(ད)། སྒྲུང་མཐའ་མ་གཅིག
མཐའ་མ་གཅིག
༼སྔན་མ་སྔན་མ་༽ཡོད་(བ)། པ་ལགས་གཅིག་སླེབས་རེད་(ད)།ཨ་མ་ལགས་གཅིག་སླེབས་རེད་(ད)།
ཨ་མ་ལགས་ཁུ་སིམ་བསྡད་བྱས་རེད་(ད)།
པ་ལགས་ཡོད་(བ)། པ་ལགས་ཚལ་ཉོ་ག་འགྲོ་རེད་(ད)།
ཨ་མ་ཡོད་(བ)། པུ་གུ་
༼མ་མ་༽སྤྲད་ད་ལབ་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽༼ར༽། རྩེད་མོ་རྩེས་ཚར་ཡིན།
པ་སངས་གཡུ་མཚོ།
ཨ་མ་གིས༼་མ་མ་༽སྤྲད་རེད། ཡོད་རེད།
བསོད་ནམས་ཚེ་སྐྱིད། རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་༼ཡ་༽ཡོད་རེད།
རྩེད་མོ་འདི།
རྩེད་མོ་་་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ཡ།
ཨ་ཅག་འདི་ཡིན་(ད)། ག་དེ་དགོས། འདི་དགོས། འདི་དགོས། ག་དེ་དགོས།
ང་ནག་པོ་མཐོང་གི་འདུག
Biscuit རག་སོང་།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། ད་དུང་ཁ་སང་སྔོན་མ་ཡོད་(བ་)སྔོན་མ་སྔོན་མ་ཡོད་(བ)།
ང་པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽(ར)།
Cake སྤྲད་སོང་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་(ར)། ང་ཁ་བརྟགས་སྤྲད་སོང་། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་ར་པར་བརྒྱབ་སོང་།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་(ར)།
ཞ་མོ་སྤྲད་སོང་། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་(ར)།
ང་ར་དགའ་པོ་ཆགས་སོང་།
དེ་ནས་ང་ཡོད་(བ)།
དེ་ནས་ང་ཡོད་(བ་)པ་ལགས་༼གིས་༽ཆུ་སྤྲད་སོང་།
༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽སེ་སྤྲད་སོང་།
ཆུ་གཅིག་པོ་སྤྲད་སོང་། འགྱིག་དམ་ནང་ལ།
དེ་ནས་ཡོད་(བ)།